or a tout cédé 0,42 soit bas c'est
génial me sim c'est qu'on en train de
travailler sur un quiz un quizz avec
carole rousseau voit la mairie
s'appellera le petit bac sur ces 8 et
voilà il dans le ca moi je vous vois
bien aussi faire le test depuis gerald
de le refaire avec plaisir mais bon le
non à l'exemple ce que benjamin est très
bon en jeu aussi ferait rien bah oui et
pas un petit bol avec des guest tous et
des anonymes se sera pas vous j'aime
beaucoup qui me loge les yeux téléphone
cet après midi elle m'a donné des infos
exclusives monde adore elle a un ami
haut placé qui lui aurait donné cette
date du 12 février mais selon elle le
confinement serait encore avancé je cite
entre la semaine prochaine et la semaine
d'après ce sera un confinement comme en
novembre plus light que le premier
confinement est selon elle le coït ce
serait un complot des puissances
mondiales à ça va jamais s'arrêter c'est
que le début et on entre dans un nouveau
système français quand
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous merci natalia
merci d'être là jouent sont déjà ému et
extrêmement triste déjà ce soir
comment vas y aurait aujourd'hui jury va
mieux
damien par contre par les moments c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est pas
encore il y aurait quand on a connu est
sorti du coma il arrive à vous parler
il arrive à prononcer quelques mots
d'accord mais par contre et hilario pas
encore à composer les phrasés s'exprimer
il va falloir opérer la tête est et
elles étaient ouvertes partout partout
on voyait les grands ouverts c'est pour
ça que ensuite je lui parle et j'ai dix
jurés qu'est ce qui s'est passé dis moi
s'il te plaît qu'est ce que c'est il
avoue yves était conscient et
l'inconscient ces moments là je vais
demander dix mois qu'est ce que s'est
passé
même les bons paysans étonné qu'il est
conscient encore parce que y'avait pas
il y avait perdu beaucoup beaucoup de
sang il m'a demandé il m'a demandé de le
venger
il m'a demandé de les retrouver et quand
je lui dis améliorer ce qui t'as fait ça
pourquoi ils ont fait ça tu leur dois
quelque chose qu'est ce qui se passe
explique moi s'il te plaît en ce moment
la durée il me dit maman je les connais
pas je les connais pas je les connais
pas ne me laisse pas mourir s'il te
plaît j'étais supplie faire au plus vite
et ne me laisse pas mourir moment vous
pouvez imaginer
en tant que maman qu'est ce que je
soutiens ces moments-là shopi meije est
restée forte
j'ai pas pleurer chez lui dit jury
j'étais promet qu'on va s'en sortir et
ruben une histoire incroyable gérant
d'une société de dératisation
c'est ça s'arrête dans la dératisation
c'est ça ça va ça se passe bien ça se
passe très bien et on a avec nous
également alors c'est paul vous êtes
ancien dératiseur c'est ça que vous avez
arrêté qu'est ce qui s'est passé par
exemple connu une très mauvaise
expérience
j'aimerais que vous nous raconter votre
histoire sans mentir c'est tout ira qui
sortent de nulle part alors c'était mon
métier
bien sûr j'ai angoisses et j'ai eu très
peur je suis parti j'ai couru chez eux
mêmes projets j'atterris sur un canapé
et non les radis pour aidants
mais bon une angoisse pas possible ils
ont couru dans que j'ai couru dans toute
la maison
vous êtes le ghana qui court après moi
c'est un truc de fou ils sont tous en
fait comme la dame et les avaient
enfermés dix ans les péchés de sorcières
il a ouvert le jeu moi j'ai ouvert le
placard
c'est thierry sol bas j'étais tout seul
face à lui raconte pas sa voilure
d'accord j'ai couru ce soir chez la
cuisine j'ai couru son canapé ils sont
ils sont partis dans toute la maison la
dame affolée elle crie de partout
allemand goisses encore plus
moi je n'ai pas nagé son canapé non non
non d'ouvrir la porte qui alors acquis
mac imac mac ramadan rappelle agents
mais il m'a mordu mais non et par
panique j'ai pas j'ai pas tout de suite
c'est le jeu c'est que j'ai eu mal
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vacciner j'ai
fait j'ai justement j'ai je suis rentré
chez moi après j'ai vu que j'avais mal
et ça commençait à me lancer j'ai eu
peur pas du coup qu'est ce que je suis
fait je suis parti à l'hôpital et ils
m'ont fait un vaccin un vaccin contre la
rage et et que tu es fort mierda mot est
ce qu'on peut dire bonnes nouvelles la
première c'est que en israël ils ont
vérifié cent trente mille personnes et
on s'est rendu compte que simplement
vingt personnes ont développé une forme
de coronavirus extrêmement légère aucun
décès aucune hospitalisation fait mal ça
marche première chance de cesser les
bonnes nouvelles les dernières nouvelles
et j'ai une deuxième chose moderna vient
d'annoncer que leur vaccin est efficace
sur le variant sud-africain magnifique
troisième bonne nouvelle sanofi qui
malheureusement n'a pas réussi à
développer un vaccin va justement
produire des flacons et des doses pour
files heures avec 100 millions de doses
supplémentaires d'ici 2021 est géniale à
me dire qu'il faut qu'on tienne encore
un petit peu oui mais que à l'horizon on
a peut-être de bonnes nouvelles il faut
qu'on tienne encore ensemble qu'on porte
un masque
il n'existe aucun traitement efficace à
l'heure actuelle et lavez vous les mains
récit des droits des uns des autres on
attend et on va s'en sortir tous
ensemble et si timide et son énorme
alors et sms sur les normes ce et c'est
juste un gars doux c'est juste le gall
déroule le 27 octobre 2009 à 21h49 il
écrit libre pour boire un verre vers un
gars qui râle on dirait moi quand je me
fais passer pour ne peut contacter plus
répond-t-elle bam
si tu veux même si j'aurais aimé prendre
un dernier verre
j'aimerais que tu me rappelles s'il te
plaît gerald ah oui là il vaut pas celle
à l'histoire
après 4 novembre à minuit les cas
nouveaux venus à toi ok mais prenons un
dernier verre mais après c'est moi qui
me suis fait passer pour kaba dame nous
aurons pour se voir comme à chaque fois
et c'est vrai que hier j'ai vu les
commentaires passés sur les réseaux
sociaux incroyable j'ai dû le voir après
en replay parce que j'étais voilà
j'étais sur une émission comme
d'habitude que je passe plus de temps
sur les plateaux télé
- qu'ils ont chez moi en train de
regarder les séries en tout cas il y
avait des moments très très fort hier 10
% de la population mondiale et mais 70%
du co2 10% et responsables de 70% des
réchauffements climatiques
c'est 10 % c'est toi c'est moi alors que
tous ici et se finit pas contre les
politiques qui n'est pas contrôlée le b
il est contre moi est ce que moi je suis
capable de changer ma façon de vivre
en voilà l'homme politique n'est que le
reflet parce que nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui les lobbys personne ne
m'oblige à mettre de l'essence dans ma
bagnole personnes mobiles de mieux
consommer de la viande industrielle
c'est moi de décider
et aujourd'hui la situation est
tellement grave que nous permet à chacun
de donner du sens à notre vie elle
qu'elle songe de l'amérique à quoi je
sers qu'est ce que je peux le faire et
si on peut tous se poser la question
il ya une grosse urgent alors il ya
votre livre sicap 2030 une décennie pour
changer le monde on va revoir d'autres
images mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on
a encore une chance de sauver la planète
ou d'abord une décennie pour changer le
monde mais de sauver la planète il a
continué à tourner on parle de sauver la
vie telle qu'elle est sa retraite
j'allume il ya 5/5 cinq extinctions sur
la terre de la vie sur terre
on parle de la sixième extinction dur à
l'homme moi je me pose pas la question
si on va y arriver au pas c'est mon
devoir c'est ma mission le fait c'est
toute seule mission ici sur le plateau
est d'essayer de faire une grille
meilleur pour nos enfants avec tout ce
qui aujourd'hui un heureux événement est
arrivé dans ma vie puisque je suis ton
ton nom
et si léché ricaine jeunes d'ici et oui
il y à deux jours d'une petite princesse
egea oui là eva alba voilà et donc je
suis ton tombe dessus ça moche ça me
rend fou quoi c'est pas génial
ah ouais ben embrasse kenji mon chéri e
sama problème avec la cgt cheminots
c'est très simple il ya un monde qui
s'est fait tabasser et on vient vous
expliquer un truc qu'ils aient
effectivement très grave
à ce moment là je trouve ça scandaleux
ça me révolte je vous dit votre pub que
vous faites maintenant ça me révolte je
ne gagne plus sur les yeux ouais bah moi
je pense que je veux dire on a des
vocations et abbas et benjamin a répondu
je ne sais pas si ça va c'est pas c'est
pas ben jama qui a écrit l'ars je ne dis
pas ça sert et d'écouter ce que je vous
dit à irin vous explique président je ne
pensais pas pouvoir judiciaire
effectivement très grave on nous le sang
au moment où un homme s'est fait
défoncer la gueule et coups de marteau
je m'en fous de savoir ce qui s'est
passé avant ou après l'union par séoul
ça va être salé que vous savez que ces
femmes là en l'occurrence c'est pas le
problème du sahara savez-vous pas que ça
va rester le parent les bains direct
lionel messi au paris saint germain
j'ai gardé très bonne nouvelle c'est que
c'est faisable le psg est vraiment sur
la liste pour engager lui à une missile
alors le salaire de mai 631 millions
c'est tout confondu le salaire de mai 6
et 50 millions bruts par saison ce sera
un contrat de trois ans ou une maman
donc il faut savoir à quel âge déjà v6
là il a 33 donc 33 ouais mais habana
naïma neymar 7,37 millions d'euros bruts
mba pc 22 millions donc mais si c'est
beaucoup plus cher
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que si messi
vient ça veut dire que quelqu'un que
vous adorez 120 ce sera m bape et je
sais que ce sera là et en liberté il est
en ce moment valorisée à 150 millions
parce que son prix a baissé en raison du
contexte sanitaire
quand je suis venu la dernière fois je
lui un an mais j'ai demandé le contrôle
des frontières
j'ai parlé de l'asie j'ai dit voilà ce
qui se passe en asie
voilà ce qu'ils font les bleus créés
frontières ils font des thèses
quarantaine et tout si on veut régler le
problème il faut peut-être confinement
mais il faut bloquer les frontières tous
vous m tomber dessus
c'est pas les mêmes qu'un pan tout le
monde m'est tombé dessus un foutu tout
le monde dehors de tout le monde m'est
tombé dessus et on m'a fait passer pour
les rangs fascisme dingue
pendant des mois j'ai réclamé le
contrôle des frontières
on m'a dit c'est pas possible le premier
ministre le ministre on dit du point il
n'y aura pas non
ils y viennent mais ils le font pas ils
ne font pas bien la solution pour éviter
à terme un confinement à perpétuité
c'est de contrôler les frontières je
préfère est enfermé dans mon pays est
enfermé à domicile parce que c'est ça le
choix mes journées pour laisser ce qui
se passe en asie l'économie privée en
asie mon resto laillé connaît mieux la
gérer on l'a tous marchent parce qu'ils
ont le courage de dire on rentre pas
mais nous ya l'idéologie sans frontières
y sont rentrés le c'est pas possible
[Musique]
on